c'est tellement vrai je me souviendrai
toujours de ce moment où est la claqué
la porte quand j'ai fait rentrer l'âne
dans la chambre
[Applaudissements]
j'accueille maintenant Gaspard Proust
pour elle est pas belle la vie
[Musique]
dimanche
j'ai chopé la grippe donc je peux dire
que toute ma vie j'ai jamais autant fait
la bise aux gens
d'habitude j'ai un herpès en même temps
et ça m'a bloqué bon on est généreux on
n'est pas enfin bon quoi de neuf plein
de trucs extraordinaires cette semaine
l'éducation nationale alors selon le
classement de la pizza en termes de
scolarité on est nul on est vraiment si
la France recule c'est par humilité on
veut pas humilier par notre niveau
scolaire les pays dont on va finir par
rejoindre le niveau de vie on est
le problème en fait c'est le niveau des
profs on a trouvé un prof qui a une
moyenne de 4 sur 20 à ces examens de
profs
pour peu que le mec a eu 18 en travaux
manuels et 16 ans flûte à bec
[Musique]
tu as une petite idée de c'est note en
maths quoi tu dis enfin le principe de
l'école c'est que c'est le prof qui
apprend au gosse pas l'inverse
avec une moyenne pareil tu m'étonnes que
les profs refont plusieurs fois la même
année c'est pas par choix c'est juste
pour finir par comprendre ce qu'ils
enseignent
alors la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il
paraît qu'on a un système très
performant pour les élites alors c'est
un système qui est adapté aux gens très
voilà c'est vrai que quand on voit les
élites françaises qu'est-ce qu'elle lui
mette à la mondialisation tu vois si
Mercedes appelle Google n'investisse pas
en France c'est juste par complexe
d'infériorité
théâtre subventionné après Olivier pipe
a trichérot la France découvre le génie
scénique de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
impressionnant de maturité tu lui donnes
un trottoir cas de figurants il te fait
Bennour
vie nocturne après David Cathy Guetta et
Régine le PS s'est mis organisé des
soirées à thème génial c'est le concept
c'est la soirée lieu commun tu vois tu
trouves une évidence tout le monde doit
être pour et boum DJ et là c'était la
soirée contre la haine alors il prévoit
aussi une soirée 1 + 1 = 2 la night de
la pluie qui mouille ça va être
alors c'est c'est vraiment les seuls
soirées où j'arrive à me trouver génial
parce que tu déblatères une banalité les
gens disent oh alors j'ai abordé
une fille je lui ai dit franchement la
une deux minutes c'est nauséabond elle
m'a dit Marine Le Pen il trouve pas que
c'est une facho
si elle a des trucs je commence à te
dire et là tu sais enfin je te
regarde dans les yeux et je viens de me
faire traverser par un sentiment étrange
mais je trouve pas que la paix ça fait
moins de mort que la guerre
et attends attends tu m'inspires un truc
au fond j'ai l'impression que tous les
hommes naissent libres et Go en droit
alors la fille scotché m'a dit toi tu as
dû faire Normal Sup pourquoi c'est
écoute on s'en fout des études ce qui
compte c'est le cœur à là elle m'a dit
on va chez toi ou chez moi je dis non
c'est gentil mais je me remettrai à
faire l'amour que lorsqu'on aura
éradiqué la fin dans le monde en
revanche une pipe aux toilettes
[Applaudissements]
foot cette polémique le PSG a commencé
son match contre Lyon sans un seul
joueur français
excusez-les d'avoir envie de gagner
[Applaudissements]
sondage alors on sent que c'est on sent
que c'est l'hiver on part déjà de la
bouffe qui colle à l'estomac ceci fait
froid les frimas le rein de Chirac la
prostate de Hollande oh mais moi je suis
un Hollande où il en est essayé de faire
du buzz avec un abat il aurait pu
trouver un morceau noble quoi tu vois
j'ai mal aux abdos
une opération de prostate qui a soulevé
beaucoup de questions c'est un phénomène
il paraît que c'est la première prostate
qui arrive à fonctionner sans testicule
[Applaudissements]
alors
on l'a retrouvé dans une crèche dans une
position bon après le président des
bisous le président des nounou cette
photo vraiment elle a fait mal mais elle
s'adresse aux Français elle a dit vous
voyez moi aussi j'ai les mains dans la
merde
mais je comprends pourquoi il a un peu
du coup c'est pas le surpoids c'est les
oreillons parce qu'à force de faire des
crèches
[Applaudissements]
international Afghanistan après 12 ans
de guerre sa progresse ils vont rétablir
la lapidation pour adultère
c'est normal c'est normal dans un pays
où il y a rien c'est quand même super
indécent d'avoir une vie sexuelle
pimentée
alors dans la foulée ils ont aussi sorti
un rapport qui estiment que les cultures
de substitution à l'opium ont échoué
non mais sans la c'est vrai que c'est
super courant le dealer qui vient de
voir en boîte et qui dit écoute j'ai pas
de coq en revanche des salsifis et des
rats du Touquet
elles viennent d'un producteur
et demain je reçois des pêches du
Roussillon ça va vraiment faire des
dégâts
[Rires]
Ukraine les manifestants veulent que
l'Ukraine intègre l'Europe ça leur
suffit pas de perdre à l'UEFA à
l'urovision ils veulent en plus se faire
humilier à la BCE
alors évidemment l'Ukraine fait du bruit
et les Femen réagissent elles ont urinés
sur la photo du président ukrainien
c'est bizarre les happniques des Femen
c'est quelque chose ça devient un mix
entre la FIAC Michaël Youn et une visite
médicale
[Applaudissements]
sexe
en matière de passer sexuel les hommes
déplorent les occasions manquées et les
femmes les expériences décevantes c'est
tellement vrai je me souviendrai
toujours de ce moment où elle a claqué
la porte quand j'ai fait rentrer l'âne
dans la chambre
[Applaudissements]
j'ai compris
ah le chanteur M a fait une prestation
dans le métro à Paris alors je veux pas
juger mais je trouve que c'est pas la
manière la plus futée de se faire du
frigo black
bon le côté positif ça va peut-être
donner des idées aux ce serait
une bonne idée les dans le
métro surtout sur les rails ce sera
non mais pas vous pas vous pas vous
enfin non vous êtes un peu à part dans
les vous êtes le seul qui
arrivait à vivre de votre métier
[Applaudissements]
bonne nouvelle alors ouais ce soir il y
a deux grosses soirées Miss France ou
Téléthon
c'est pas par machisme je préfère Miss
France c'est quand même plus facile de
s'attacher à des personnes dont on est à
peu près sûr qu'elle passeront l'hiver
et qui pour les plus talentueux se
finiront peut-être dans un porno alors
pas belle la vie
pour être sûr de ne rien
radariser abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu